[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans ce sillon
sortait aujourd'hui nous sommes au
cabaret du bout des prêts à cerner la
ville et on est en compagnie de tony
bastion le responsable du cabaret
bonjour bonjour merci d'être là
alors ce cabaret il a il fête cette
année ses dix ans quel est le concept du
cabaret ici le concept du cabaret c'est
d'accueillir les gens de les faire dîner
et ensuite de leur donner le meilleur de
nous-mêmes pour un pour une jolie soirée
un beau spectacle
voilà donc on est ici au milieu d'eux
chant des on est dans un petit village
pourquoi ici alors tout simplement le
hasard et l'amour voilà le hasard parce
que je suis arrivé pour faire une
animation dans l'auberge du bout des
prix juste à côté
et puis la grange je suis tombé dessus
aussi est visuellement il y avait un bon
potentiel j'ai réussi à convaincre
quelques années le propriétaire des
lieux pour pour en faire quelque chose
et puis l'amour parce que ben mon épouse
est en danseuse et s'occupant des
costumes on travaillait déjà à
l'extérieur on s'est dit qu'on pouvait
s'installer ici
voilà donc vous vivez sur site on vit
dans un 3 minutes d'ici voilà un côté
mais oui on dit fait quasiment ici est
donc le cabaret la rouvre le 26
septembre
enfin après ce que le confinement
comment vous vous sentez vous il ya
encore une semaine je me sentais un peu
lourd est là depuis la reprise des
répétitions
je me sens bien physiquement et surtout
très heureux de reprendre parce que on
était un peu comme comme des enfants
devant un sapin de noël sans pouvoir
ouvrir les cadeaux
voilà comment ça s'est passé les
précautions à prendre vous avez reçu ça
un peu dernièrement this way ça a été
compliqué parce que en juillet on a eu
on a eu un premier protocole qui n'était
pas officielle et puis on a attendu
attendu pour savoir quand est ce qu'on
pouvait reprendre les répétitions et on
sait on s'est aligné sur ce protocole de
départ pour faire attention donc ce
masque est hors de la scène se laver les
mains enfin toutes les précautions
d'usagé
voilà et donc là vous ouvrez avec un
spectacle comédie musicale comédie
musicale qui nous fait chanter qui nous
donne un petit peu envie de danser
ce que vous nous en parler qui est mario
quelle est l'histoire marque je joue le
rôle de mario qui est le propriétaire
d'une pizzeria est en fait mario est un
est une fleur bleue qui tombe amoureux
de la danseuse du cabaret du bout des
prix qui est juste à côté de sa pizzeria
et forcément il a promis de d'offrir la
pizza quatre saisons à celle qu'il aime
voilà donc il se peut que la carte soit
garni s'il arrive à séduire cette
fameuse la lie voilà et les chants les
musiques qu on peut alors ça se passe
dans les années 60 donc forcément le
thème et les thèmes musicaux sont
beaucoup de titres des années 60 et
aussi quelques compositions
qu'on a voulu qu'on a voulu intégrer
pour pouvoir aussi donner au public des
nouveautés pour l'oreille
voilà pour la forme c'était bien et donc
tout le monde chante si j'ai bien
compris
la particularité de ce spectacle c'est
un vrai défi et je remercie vraiment mes
artistes qui sont à la base des danseurs
et danseuses et qui ont accepté le défi
de jouer la comédie et chanter avec moi
parce que je me sentais seule en fait
avant j'étais le maître de cérémonie le
chanteur des spectacles cabarets et donc
on n'était jamais ensemble et donc on a
pris le pari et ce qui était assez
rigolo c'est que quelques mois avant le
début du spectacle certains me disaient
non n'est jamais tu me fera chanter et
finalement maintenant ils sont très
heureux de chanter et ça donne plein
plein de possibilités au spectacle et au
cabaret puis il chante très juste aussi
ouais on a beaucoup bossé et j'ai envie
de dire et je le dis pour tout le monde
sait chanter juste et avant tout prendre
du plaisir à chanter la justesse elle
est surtout dans l'intention mais il ya
de la tension il ya du bonheur et c'est
le principal pour nous prendre du
plaisir je vous entends dire prendre du
plaisir c'est aussi une part importante
du spectacle c'est le final de notre
spectacle c'est un peu c'est un peu la
conclusion du spectacle et c'est en ces
temps un peu compliqué annoncé ça au
final il ya il ya une vraie émotion elle
dire au public et on espère que le
message va passer malgré tout parce que
voilà il ya aussi prendre du plaisir je
pense à tous mes collègues artistes qui
ne peuvent pas reprendre
nous on va en prendre mais on va penser
aussi fort à ceux qui ne peuvent pas
reprendre pour l'instant voilà et donc
justement comment ça se passe pour les
mesures sanitaires dans la salle est ce
qu'on pourra dîner alors oui tout à fait
les protocoles ont été annoncés moi je
les connais pas par coeur c'est plutôt
en salle qu'ils vont s'en occuper mais
je crois savoir que nous avons déjà
réduit notre spectacle de façon à ce que
les gens puissent dîner dans un premier
temps en enlevant le masque et se re
masqué pour voir notre spectacle qui
fera maintenant un format d'une heure
vingt
vous êtes combien sur scène on est huit
pareil à cause du coc vides ont été 10
et à cause de l'épidémie on est on est
repassé à 8 pour des raisons de distance
entre entre les gens au début on savait
pas donc on s'est adapté donc cette
année c'est vos dix ans les 10 ans du
cabaret qu'est ce que vous avez prévu
alors on a prévu il ya une date
anniversaire au mois de février 2021
donc comme ça fait partie de cette
saison le premier spectacle va avoir
lieu aux environs du mois de décembre je
crois si tout va bien et nous allons
faire un melting-pot de tous les
spectacles que nous avons fait jusqu'ici
en disant plus des nouveautés
voilà donc c'est un gros spectacle et le
thème là c'est plumes strass et
paillettes le cabaret comme comme tout
le monde le voit donc il ya le cas de
saison qui est une comédie musicale mais
là le spectacle déjà dix ans qui est
prévue sera vraiment un spectacle de
cabaret pur je crois qu'à savoir qu'il
ya un troisième spectacle oui alors
après c'est plus des soirées à thème
pour aussi agrandir le public qui vient
nous voir parce qu'on a des demandes de
danse est donc pour l'instant ce n'est
pas évident mais on avait prévu de faire
des soirées 80 et 90 plutôt en mode
spectacle debout qu'on ne fera pas pour
l'instant mais on propose 7 ce spectacle
parce que on a bossé pour un mode dîner
spectacle
je pense que le plaisir sera quand même
là on pourra pas danser seulement mais
on pourra prendre du plaisir aussi
ok va très bien merci beaucoup dany
bastien si d'autres que lui je vous
invite grandement à venir voir ce
spectacle qui vous fera danser chanter
et puis nous on va on se retrouvera
bientôt pour de nouvelles sorties dans
les yvelines
[Musique]
dick